bonjour hubert julien laferrière merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france on va revenir sur
vos allait être régulière au
gouvernement sur la situation au yémen
mais peut-être avant un point sur la
situation 6 en guerre pas de
perspectives de paix au début de semaine
l'arabie saoudite a proposé un
cessez-le-feu refusé pour le moment par
les outils alors comment est ce que vous
le comprenez pas parce que effectivement
c'est une guerre terrible qui date
depuis le printemps a ramené en
particulier le drame se joue depuis
l'intervention de la coalition samedi au
émiriennes alors c'est vrai que là
depuis quelques jours les outils ans
on gagne et quelques batailles et du
coup ils ont renforcé leurs positions
mais si vous voulez quand vous voyez
c'est très bien lille dans votre
reportage que cette opération tempête
décisive était censé durer deux jours et
que le pays s'est enlisé dans ce conflit
avec un drap un drame humanitaire
terrible qui se joue un l'onu à la
qualifiée de pire drame humanitaire qui
sévit actuellement dans le monde
donc il ya effectivement aujourd'hui de
nouvelles données mais ce qu'il faut
retenir aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a une
coalition qui bombardé et qui est quand
même resté responsable de ce drame
humanitaire avec un tiers de la
population qui souffre de la famine dont
une moitié d'enfants avec plusieurs
peut-être quinze mille victimes civiles
donc c'est un drame terrible qui se joue
en vrille et mène et on peut pas fermer
les yeux voyez quand on voit c'est très
bien dit dans notre reportage les
etats-unis l'italie qui remettent en
question des contrats d'armement
la france ne veut pas fermer les yeux la
france qui s'enorgueillit d'être le pays
des droits de l'homme qui occupe une
place singulière sur la scène
internationale aujourd'hui on peut pas
continuer à dire bien on n'a pas de
preuve que les armes que l'on vend à la
coalition sont directement responsables
de victimes civiles
c'est pas possible de tenir un tel
discours
il ya plusieurs organisé est
effectivement inquiet qui alerte sur
cette question des ventes d'armes
regardez ce que disait oxfam c'était en
février dernier alors justement 80% de
la population au yémen voit sa survie
dépendre de l'aide humanitaire dont plus
de 12 millions d'enfants
on y voit une dégradation des conditions
de vie près de la moitié des moins de
cinq ans souffrent de la malnutrition
aiguë aujourd'hui il ya une situation de
famine avec des problèmes d'accès à
l'eau potable auquel seulement un tiers
de la population a accès alors
effectivement c'était sur la situation
sanitaire on vient entendre philippe
duhamel sur la situation sanitaire vous
en parliez vous parliez et
notamment aussi de cette question la
vente des armes on va peut-être pouvoir
entendre ce que l'alerté de l'oms et aux
femmes c'était en février dernier il est
temps que la france respecte ses
engagements internationaux relatifs au
traité sur le commerce des armes et à la
position commune 2008 944 psc de l'union
européenne dès lors qu'il existe le
risque que des pays utilisent des armes
françaises contre des civils la france
doit cesser de leur en fournir
voilà la bande d'armes françaises des
députés aussi avait essayé d'alerter un
oui oui tout à fait et là vous avez tout
à fait raison de rappeler cette position
commune de l'union européenne parce
qu'il ya un vrai problème en france 2 de
transparence des ventes d'armes
mon collègue sébastien nadeau
effectivement à verte et là dessus avait
demandé une commission denquête et et
mes collègues de la majorité de jacques
maire et celle tabarot et ont fait un
rapport qu'ils ont rendue il ya quelques
quelques semaines ou quelques mois pour
plus globalement pas pas seulement sur
ce conflit mais pour dire il faut qu'il
y ait davantage de transparence dans les
ventes d'armes
aujourd'hui on est on est dans l'opacité
et on est une exception française est
d'inciter à écouter ce jeu ne s'est pas
complètement l'expliquer il ya toujours
eu un un blocage des gouvernements
français à ce que y ait davantage de
transparence et la transparence à
l'égard notamment des parlementaires des
représentations de la nation est
évidemment indispensable
c'est surtout le secteur de l'armement
c'est un secteur important de l'économie
française c'est pour ça qu'il ya cette
opacité
mais de dire quand aujourd'hui les états
unis la première puissance mondiale
montrent l'exemple en prend sans cesse
aux gestes très forts de ma voix
remettre en question les ventes d'armes
à la coalition saudoyer mérienne il faut
que ça nous laisse réfléchir mais vous
avez bien site est effectivement ce bien
bien décrit ce drame america qui se joue
avec des enfants qui sont touchés on
pourrait y ajouter le choléra qui se
développe donc là il ya vraiment un
sujet sur lesquels il faut il faut
absolument
sensibiliser aussi nos populations parce
qu'on ne pas qu'on ne parle pas assez de
se compliquer encore une fois et est
qualifié comme la pire catastrophe
humanitaire contemporaine par les
nations unies elles mêmes qui ont
d'ailleurs également décrit des crimes
de guerre des crimes de guerre commis
par la coalition par les coalitions à
deux pays avec lesquels nous entretenons
des relations diplomatiques tout à fait
normal et auquel nous vendons des armes
et où je viens de voir il ya quelques
jours que des nouveaux contrats de vente
d'armes à l'arabie saoudite allait être
signé
alors qu'est ce que vous attendez
justement aujourd'hui de la france plus
précisément du ministre des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian
ben écoute moi moi moi moi j'attends que
au delà de dire ce qu'il a dit lui-même
que c'était une sale guerre
et bien que le gouvernement prenne en
compte ces défis cesser ce drame qui se
joue et et prennent des décisions il
faut absolument passer de la parole aux
actes parce que à chaque fois que nous
avons interrogé le gouvernement
on nous a expliqué qu'effectivement
c'était une sale guerre qu'il fallait
que la communauté internationale se
réunit ce qu'il fallait absolument que
la paix
se joue dans le dans le pays mais mais
sans qu'il y ait aucune décision
concrète et donc moi j'attends déjà
qu'on puisse suivre le chemin qui est
empruntée par parler de ta vie et par
d'autres pays comme l'italie et que l'on
puisse remettre en cause certains
contrats d'armement et surtout qu'on
puisse avoir un discours plus ferme à
l'égard de l'arabie saoudite et des
émirats arabes unis dans votre reportage
où vous citiez à juste titre le général
ahmad al asiri à remède à la syrie qui a
été porte parole de la coalition
donc de la guerre au yémen et qui est de
nom le sait depuis que le rapport de la
cia a été révélée qui a été le cerveau
de l'assassinât horrible de jamal
khashoggi c'est quand même des raisons
qui devraient pouvoir nous pousser à
hausser un petit peu le ton vis-à-vis de
ces pays en décembre dernier vous aviez
aussi vous aviez aussi alerté pendant le
ministre ministère des affaires
étrangères sur l'utilisation d'un site
total à part les émirats arabes unis
comme une prison qu'en est il
aujourd'hui
oui alors c'est un sujet sur vraiment
particulière puisque au yémen
effectivement sur le site de balhaf il y
a un site gazier donc tenu par la
société lng société yéménite mais dans
le dans lequel la société total est
actionnaire majoritaire
est ce ce site a bénéficié d'une
garantie d'emprunt de la bpi la banque
publique française dont de l'argent
public et ce site a été investi par par
le gouvernement du yémen et pour le
compte des émirats années qui l'ont
transformé en prison secrète et dont on
sait grâce à aux enquêtes des ong qui se
joue des tortures sur place et donc
c'est quand même oui un problème sur
lequel on a souhaité alerter le
gouvernement
lorsqu'on sait qu'un psy qui a bénéficié
d'argent public est transformée en
prison et/ou vraisemblement il y à des
crimes de guerre et des tortures qui
sont eux qui sont opérés par les émirats
arabes unis donc la moindre des choses
aussi là ce serait que le gouvernement
français ait effectivement demande
clairement des explications j'ai même
rencontré le président de total patrick
pouyanné mais en tout cas ce qui je joue
aujourd'hui sur ce site c'est quand même
qu'il a été investi par la coalition
enfin par un acteur de la commission en
l'occurrence les émirats arabes unis qu
dès que des crimes de guerre sont
perpétrés sur ce site qui a bénéficié
d'argent public de la france donc je
crois que là aussi il faut hausser le
ton et demander des explications fermes
à ce pays merci beaucoup hubert julien
laferrière d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans la matinale de rtl
france le rappelle vous êtes députés
d'écologie démocratie solidarité du
rhône